le fromage un produit qui a du sens
depuis la nuit des temps pour ludovic
biseau la boutique de ce meilleur
ouvrier de france situé à rambouillet
est l'un des premiers de l'hexagone à
avoir sur sa devanture une plaque
d'ambassade de la gourmandise
oui j'ai triplé mes prix immédiatement
et j'ai installé un service de voiturier
pour les rolls qui viennent tout à fait
le fromager affineur allie qualité et
humour dans son commerce il est
notamment à l'initiative d'un tournoi
baptisé roland claque hausse cette
nouvelle distinction lui a été décernée
par l'académie nationale de gourmandise
qui compte dans ses rangs david douillet
ou encore le prince guillaume de triche
c'est pas une opération mercantile
pas du tout c'est un titre un peu
honorifique qui qui voilà qui a
un écho médiatique qui rend les mes
clients ici à rambouillet très fier et
moi aussi donc c'est voilà c'est
chouette
ludovic biseau s'envole aujourd'hui à
new york pour la ligue des fromagers
extraordinaire pour permettre à notre
patrimoine gastronomique de traverser
les frontières